there's no puberty ceremony in culture  as an American man when do you become a  man when you get a driver's license like  what do we do you 16 we give you a  driver's license okay like you get a job  like when do you become a man you become  a man when you become responsible for  other people and part of that is taking  accountability and so like I I'm very  new to this being a man thing and I'm  still not there and I'm on a path  um but I didn't have no like  I grew up on a in a culture that told me  going to war made you a man going to  prison and coming back coming back makes  you a man making a million dollars makes  you a man you know and and it doesn't  and you don't know it till you've done  all these things and realize damn I'm  still a little [ __ ] boy or been  around people who've been there a bunch  of times you know I don't know nothing  about being a war like Kevin but I know  a bunch of soldiers that come back are  still little boys